anyway we're gonna do something new
today there's a new game that's been
released it was released last week it's
been some update since then it's a
mobile app it's called choker which it's
a non violent game and the name comes
from the combination of chess and poker
and I've played it a little bit I've
made some intention to like not kick not
try and get really good at it to try and
learn as I go of course like the chess
aspect of it will be will be hopefully
my strong points
poker aspect we'll see but I'm gonna
play a game and for those of you who
have not heard of this will kind of
learn as we go
I think I'll find a match and we'll do
the lowest stakes but yeah my username
is just Eric Rosen all one word no
spaces and yeah so if people add me as a
friend I'll be more likely to play them
but this is a random opponent and
playing guest guess two four one one
eight two bishops starting the game with
the bishop here so I should like try and
explain how this works essentially
there's three phases you start the game
with a certain number of chips
looks like my opponent bought in for
2006 I started with 6000 so maybe it's
already lopsided and then you're dealt
cards which are chess pieces and there's
a betting face I'm gonna be passive here
I'm gonna I just want to get to the the
chess face so assuming we we go through
the rounds of betting then it will it
will kind of transform into chess well
this is a pretty strong hands like
normally I should bet this
I pointed checking I'm gonna place a
very small bennett's hold that like yeah
I just have to pops oh I should make a
choker command if people won't install
the game I forgot to do this beforehand
I have a link here that should work
I just left all the links in the chat so
depending what device you have you can
you can get the game okay
so white moves first so this is a
placement phase which means we take
turns placing the cards that we would
that we were dealt the place a pawn I
think pawn chains are typically good
place upon enough six Scotty Corp thanks
for subbing and I'll be left with like a
strong kind of distribution pieces the
rooks will belong on open files let's
try and be flexible though place a
bishop it's a nice square for the bishop
[Music]
yeah so for those of you confused just
keep watching hopefully it'll make sense
once all the pieces are placed we play
chess and yeah it's okay guaranteed that
we're gonna have different pieces this
is interesting because the bishop is
attacking my bishop I should have no
fear let's uh this place of rook on open
file
and this first round it's really just
demonstration I'll try and answer any
media questions related to the scheme
[Music]
yeah maybe it's not making sense so far
because we haven't reached the chess
phase yet so we place pieces back and
forth once we placed all our pieces
white will move first let's place a
bishop I should place the bishop on the
territory let's place our here attacking
the d4 pawn can you castle that's a good
question I think I think castling is
allowed if you place your rook in the
corner
Oh a pawn has a queen and threatening
maiden one so I have to place a rook to
stop mate in one this will be
interesting actually let's place the
rook Queen c6 also a threat I'll place a
rock on b8 okay
so third and final play phase is a chess
phase I do I used to play normal poker a
lot more I did go through a poker face
when I was in college but then I
eventually got more interested in chess
but okay this is kind of the best of
both worlds
Wow a lot of things are being attacked
so my bishop any sevens attacked but our
bishops are staring each other castling
maybe is playable I can't take on b2
because I got mated I could throw in the
check should probably okay I have an
idea I'm gonna take on a two first it's
actually very interesting position if I
take on a two first white will play
Queen takes a seven most likely I also
don't know how good my opponent is a
chess I guess we're about to find out
I'm calculating Queen takes a seven and
then I check first oh that doesn't quite
work though cuz oh hey check first
there's gonna be Queen a8 in the end and
my bishops attacks - ok so hopefully my
opponent doesn't see Queen eight because
I wanted to take on b2 probably taking
on b2 immediately was queen eight would
win the rook on h8 this is unfortunate
and again if rook takes b2 Queen eight
will win on each one so I'll take the
knight and then I'll take the bishop
it'll be queen for Bishop and rook and
time is relevant just a blue saying this
faith should be bullets yeah it's um I
think we each started 90 seconds this is
a new game so I'm sure there will be
like improvements along the way but
there's I think this is the first
version like released to the public this
game is hilarious yeah I think there's a
lot of like game theory and strategy
involved especially in the betting phase
but okay I like the fact I have a time
advantage I have a feeling my opponent
will flag eventually
jaesuk basem is cheering for me
appreciate that yeah you can cheer with
your words or with your bits let's play
the only reasonable move
yeah looks like opponent will end up
flagging I'll give a check on c4
I mean objectively objectively likes
better but I think black would have some
drawing chances here
I'll have to be careful I can't even
play rook h1 check ok let's play Queen
a3 coming
I guess Queen f3 all have Bishop f5 ooh
this should have seven okay I'm
sheltered from the checks so we're gonna
see a dirty flag most likely and even if
this were like just a long chess game I
think black has a fortress here
I got win the d5 pawn I would probably
play this for a win in real chess and
yeah we're gonna have a lot of end games
like if we get to the chest phase if no
one folds move free Queen is this what
we call a Cho tez ganden who said that
Peter balkis said that shout out to
Peter Bacchus ok I won the pots so I won
the amount of chips that were initially
bet if I had gone all in my point called
then I would have won the whole game so
the game continues and we each alternate
between small by small blind and big
blind I believe
I guess I I couldn't play a boat ed
scammed at that last game because I
didn't start with a queen waiting for
opponents bets maybe if one is petrified
or contemplating okay I might I might
click the X button because I don't know
what's going on like we were just stuck
let's let's find a new opponent attack
to continue okay let's try and find
someone who's like a real person do I
have any oh I have friend requests three
accept accept accept okay so the three
people whose friend request I just
accepted I think you can send me a
challenge two pawns this is maybe the
worst starting hands and the one thing
about streaming this is my opponent
could stream snipe me so well this is a
$10,000 or 10,000 chip buy-in okay let's
check oh but there's a concept of a full
house let's go back to the infographic
if I got a full house it's called an
empress okay so it's called an empress
here then there will be a promotion to a
queen ah so this is an example the third
night becomes a queen and then there's
some defense
[Music]
Oh growler is muting the stream okay
that's a good song
hopefully not looking at the stream
either what's bad what's that like let's
bet the whole pots
hey I won by my opponent folding so we
didn't even get to the chess phase
interesting
so maybe my opponent will be a bit more
cautious than usual not the most
exciting hand Bishop and pawn I'll call
ya so assuming we get through the rounds
of betting then we play chess I don't
get scared too easily but my appoint
guiding against me makes me slightly
scared what is this this is called
choker chess + poker we're in the
bedding phase
yeah I'll check again we'll try and like
get as many rounds of chess as possible
this is another concept of promotion the
third pawn I think upgrades to a row
let's check again yeah going back to
this infographic promotions pawns are
promoted if you receive three or more
third pawn is always going to a rook
okay oh let's call okay so opponent
probably has a good hand if they're
fighting against me
yeah every every round the cards are
read out so you'll get different hands
every time okay so this is a placement
face I'm still not sure how to like what
the best strategy is no place a pawn in
g4 because pawn chains are good okay
this is good sign that opponent also has
pawns if my opponent has a queen I'll
probably just be worse but we'll see
Fiona Chavo welcome back
shout out to Fiona quite streamed with
just a few days ago what to do let's
place a bishop I want to have the threat
of work h8 so let's place a bishop
actually gonna place it on d2 because if
my opponent has a queen I'll have better
winning chances of this obstacle our
bishops I guess also better losing
chances mmm yeah Fiona if you want to
add me as a friend
my name is Eric Rosen well hey this is
interesting because if I place a rook
I'll be threatening a rock h8 but my
opponent will have ideas of rock a1 I'm
trying to calculate like rook h1 rook h1
will basically force my opponent to play
something on FA g8 and g7 whether it be
a queen or rook and then I'll play
Bishop c3 this is a one thing that
varies about chess like the concept of
placing pieces now I forgot my time
begins ticking in the placement phase
which is relevant I believe
okay so I'll be threatening or gates see
if a pawn sees the threats do I have a
friend code oh oh dear all pointing to
have a queen
okay so let's play Bishop c3 oh so
another thing you can only place the
pieces on the first two ranks pawns can
be placed between the second and the
fourth ring okay so this is interesting
like I'm I'm probably better at chess in
my opponent but my opponent has better
pieces and we're playing for a pot of
3.6 K chips and I'm down on time - so
I'm down on material I'm down on telling
but I have I have Bishop before ideas I
like the facts that I went for obstacle
Archbishop's and bishops for could be
nice and black we'll have to be careful
not to step into a fork yeah let's start
with Bishop before on if you want to get
the game it's just called choker you can
go to I think that's easiest just to go
to whatever links in the chat depending
on what device you have Wow do I have
meeting ideas I mean I have I can't take
too much time rook h6 let's play rook
team one threatening rookie 655 we'll
have 95
[Music]
but okay like material-wise it's a queen
okay let's play 56 it was a queen for a
night
I think opponent will have to take on d6
otherwise I'll have Rick d6 coming okay
rook b6 I'm winning back
I'm just winning the Queen for free as I
unleash the the bishop and I obstruct
the Queen you from being able to take
the bishop okay that was a very nice
gift yeah black should have taken on d6
Bach should probably play d5 earlier
just to stop 46 we have a touchdown
emoji it's a slightly different game but
[Music]
yeah things are looking good now just
have to watch the time
that's okay let's play this move you're
gonna try and meet the King in the
center
let's take here each is hanging but then
I'll play King g3
so if yeah I know there's there's gonna
be people challenging me I do want to
have a gaming as Fionna
so if Fiona's around when this match
finishes try and look to to get a game
let's put their work on g7 I have a nice
meeting idea if black attacks a bishop
I'm not gonna move the bishop I'll play
Knight f5 oh no my bishop might be local
bishop okay I mean I know my opponents
not stream sniping but I was nice okay
so I won the pot came back from material
deficit so now I have I four thousand
more chips in my opponents and now I'm
the big blinds calm Cuervos says I think
I'm into choking now is choking the act
of playing Joker let's just Bluff my
points raise pot two pawns probably the
worst starting hands though I'm not sure
cuz if I got another pawn it would turn
into a rook yeah I'm still not sure what
like the worst starting hand is best
starting hand has to be Queen Anne drunk
so if you got two queens and one of the
Queen gets demoted to a pawn another hat
with two pots
okay I'll just call hey okay so the the
pawn got promoted to rook if I got a
second pawn just to show the rules
I've hung about 400 yeah let's call if I
got a second pawn it gets promoted to a
queen oh I did I got Delta Queen anyway
okay beautiful let's sum I mean that's
about half the pot okay this is a pretty
good hand so I think generally it's
unlikely that the point will have a
clean man opponents playing very
conservatively which is okay I keep
winning chips it's fine with me Oh
Fionna saying she had one with two pawns
and three minor pieces that has to be
the worst hand and this is a third hand
girl I have two pawns yeah but he said
earlier that he muted it which is very
ethical but I guess even if he knew that
he could see possibly but it's okay
I would request that people who play me
don't look at my cards
okay another promotion so true rooks and
knights okay I'll call we'll have
another chess phase okay I think I'll
employ the same pawn chain I had earlier
might have some symmetrical structure if
my opponent does the same thing Oh
[Music]
interesting comment from Shivan Basel
knows nothing about poker
so even looking won't help yeah I guess
you you do have to understand like the
betting aspect of Poker to play this but
but imagine it's not too difficult to to
catch on I think I'm safe placing a real
con on each aids oh and less oh yeah I
was gonna say if like faces a rock on
each one white gets the first move I
could yeah let's have I have to be
really careful here let's imagine I
place her work on h7 then if my point
has a queen places on b1 I just I'm just
lost I would be lost for garlis my
opponent has a queen I feel like I'm
just in trouble here let's play some
night
I'm bad feeling about this
aha okay so let's just not get me that
because upon threatening she opponent is
threatening Queen CA but I have 98 it's
not pleasant a place our recon undie
eight so my rook on h8 is defended by my
Knights I would actually really like to
castle if I get the chance but we'll see
what happens I guess there's some
there's some similarity to crazy house
but it's a bit different because there's
just one placement phase
there's no placing once the chess phase
begins so this will be actually a really
true test to my opponents chess ability
so I would still imagine it takes it
take a somewhat experienced player to be
me candidly in this position so I'm just
gonna like try and be solid play so rook
on d6 9 and g6 Targhee I think you are a
sub but you're also the bits leader and
you're also a mod so you can only have
like only a few badges can it display
next to your name but I'm not sure oh
maybe maybe you weren't a sub but now
you're a sub that's so funny
I'm in big trouble here okay let's let's
develop the knight just worried about my
white squares like if Queen e6 likes
running two different mates in - thanks
dog i25 gifting Talia sub
so the idea is king each six and then I
just have to pray I have to pray to the
higher higher beings and then I have to
pray on my opponent's Queen so do two
different forms of praying oh man no
like this is so unfortunate because
there's two different meetings words
there's g6 and h7 I mean this is only
move to survive and now my pawns are
gonna fall yeah I opponents playing as
well my only hope I'm hoping to get a
king to g3 and then mates on a1 but that
wouldn't even be me cuz Bishop could
block
my rooks tied down to defending the
night so I think my only hope is time at
this point which I do have slightly more
of you were a sub 60 minutes ago maybe
you subbed like exactly a month ago oh
my gosh well there goes my king okay so
that's that's choke means you used to
say choke means it's now defeated
slightly less terrifying okay let's uh
I'm still a handle like overall
I didn't lose too many chips a pot that
was actually the first pot I lost okay I
have a rook ooh two rungs
so I've to remind myself what happens if
I owe if I got a third rook it gets
demoted to a pawn
let's call
ah that's unfortunate
I could probably bad and just make my
own fold
I'll bet them in the moment you're
watching choker it's a combination of
chess and poker okay this is actually a
very reasonable hands or bet I should
bet Oh
oops I checked maybe my opponent will
bet and then I'll raise how good are you
at poker I first played poker when I was
like I'm gonna raise Tom's
I played the National Open in Vegas
chess tournament I did really badly in
the chess tournament and I stayed one
extra day and I was 21 so I played poker
in the casino first time playing live
live game of poker and I did well like
I've I won basically enough to cover him
all of my trip expenses let's place a
pawn and then I went through a bit of a
phase but yeah chess was more still
slightly more interesting Oh opponent
lost connection okay I appoint regain
connection if I place a pawn it will
give away that I have two rooks but
that's okay mm-hmm I could place on e4
could be interesting let's place it on
g4
keeping the same structure and this is a
a more kind of experimental stream
first-time streaming the game getting a
sense of the the ins and outs also I'm
just getting a sense of how to play
okay I'll place a rook I saw rook on the
edge so how ice yeah that's a good
question how am i streaming this from I
installed a virtual machine on my
desktop
it's called BlueStacks allows me to
install android apps on on the computer
so I'm not playing from a mobile device
deadman how's it going welcome back yeah
it's still it's still a very new game I
know I know there are like improvements
a lot of suggestions like ways to
improve overall user experience like how
it pronounces the hashtag nerd thanks
for subbing yeah so I guess Hoggy Hoggy
is a also a chess and poker player I'm
curious like how many people in the chat
are like familiar with poker or play
poker
I assume everyone's familiar with chess
oh okay so I'm up material upon it being
kind of safe but this should be pretty
straightforward win
actually if Knights if Knight f2 e6 I'll
have Queen g6 check and this should just
be lights out
I'm quite nice
[Music]
okay rook rook their problem is 98 and
go play Brooke a 5 or K fives nice move
a fiona has to go soon yeah this is
turning out to be a longer match than
expected like components putting up
resistance allen ck art thanks for
subbing but I'll definitely have to
organize a match with Fiona maybe we can
even like plan it ahead now that I'm
back in st. Louis this should be it
should just be easier to have like dual
streams you can even have you appear
somewhere like through video call whoa
all these people all these new subs at
once let's play Queen h7 just trying to
strangle the King a lot of people to
think wow well let's give some things to
comb comb a Cuervos and Wallace okay
this is just crushing it looks like
campus Ringling thanks so much everyone
okay yeah thanks for stopping by Fiona
shout out it's a few and Chetta yeah I'm
not going to take the Queen I'm gonna
first go in the check and then probably
take with rook
Queen GA coming point resigns or folded
I guess so I won I think I want a pretty
big pot there now it's fifteen thousand
to five thousand and the games continue
I think I'll start betting more
aggressively even even with bad hands up
unfolded yeah it seems like upon this
movie just waiting for a good hand I
don't want to go all in like garbage
cards I'm not gonna go all in with two
pawns but just have to wait for the
right opportunity I think my point is
probably waiting for the right
opportunity so just shove
let's call Jess we've stopping by what's
up Chesapeake shout out Swede another
pawn I mean that's uh basically half the
game is chess oh that does okay so yeah
three pawns going back to the PDF guide
the third pawn is where is it third pawn
me comes a rook fourth phone becomes a
queen
fifth plum is also a queen I think it's
very unlikely to receive five pawns in a
row though who invented this concept
chess and poker go to choker game calm
and you can find out more information
I'm just gonna die all the time let's
see if we can get another chess phase
but these are honestly not the greatest
cards like I don't have a queen
I'll check actually opponent also checks
okay I got it
let's sum I'm black this white should
have the advantage
let's bet opponent seems a week when i
say a week i mean like the cards seem
week based on the betting pattern so
there's no such thing as a flush in this
game because the the cards are just
chess pieces going back to here the
possible cards are there's 44 cards user
this is a breakdown of queens bishops
rooks
knights and pawns
[Music]
let's call but there are special hands
like okay here is a promotion ooh here's
another promotion I'm just saying how
unlikely it is to get like so many pawns
in a row oh this is actually quite nice
if I got another pawn I'll get a second
Queen I don't want to I want to get to
the chess face I'll bet the minimum
please call
[Music]
otherwise like if my point keeps folding
the the chips will be slowly drained and
eventually I shouldn't win okay we have
a call this will be fun I think I should
have in a better hand is it possible to
get five Queens no I think the maximum
possible is is two if I'm not mistaken
you can see the on the guide here hmm
place a pawn I've been doing the
structure every time I should try and
mix it up an experiment every every few
minutes we got the comment what am i
watching this is choker this chess and
poker we're in the placement phase I'll
probably put this full stream on YouTube
so for YouTube people hopefully you've
absorbing slowly but surely how this is
working
why LightSquared bishop good question I
placed a bishop on light square because
blacks King is on the light square and I
was threatening both dish at a4 and
Bishop g6
so I think I'm guaranteed I guarantee
you the better hands yes a pony could
potentially have working Queen
I could be very close to meeting
actually debating between a1 and b1
let's play b1 I'll be threatening in
Queen b5 or Bishop a4
oh my opponent I think my opponent just
reacted to something was interesting oh
I have to shove a fork there should be
four just wins on the spot but I don't
know if a point could have done anything
about that his Queen d7 was about the
best move
just stop the checks along the diagonal
or wait no his other rook that's a rook
nevermind I thought that was a queen for
a moment yeah I opponent was just in big
trouble so I can go like thumbs up all I
can react I was wondering what these
buttons do that's funny so I guess you
can't like chat with your opponent huh
okay so I've won I think I've won
everything but one pot what's going on I
think this happened did this happened
earlier what's the approach just exits
again really the main point of the
stream is just to play and like
understand some strategy yeah something
went wrong here I'm gonna leave leaving
the match will lose the pots but I think
I still walk away with more chips so got
my uh my share
let's do one more match
this next one I'll probably be quite
aggressive
whoa I just accepted the first thing I
don't know what I accepted but I
accepted something
okay I'm playing a plain black Who am I
playing I'm playing stock this
good luck sock this sock to us in the
chat saying I'll look away okay
sock this is a mod long time viewer
programmer I've had I have two minor
pieces
I think I'll bet I just want to get a
sense of his style
oh I checked I meant to bet I'll bet
here yeah let's bet
[Music]
hmm so I have four minor pieces and a
pawn okay trying to remember I think
stock this is actually a pretty good
chess player
I'll bet anyway see what the situation
is I do have the bishop here the bishop
pair is only effective if I place the
bishops on different colored squares
placement time okay pawn d3
I'll do the same play some copycats
approach
okay so upon it has two pawns at least
you can't have more than two pawns I
don't think be careful with my bishops
20 nights
I mean if White has a queen then I'll be
I'll be much worse but so far I I like
what I see Bishop on b7 if I want to be
really safe I can play some knight on
undie eight can you have three pawns I
guess if a pawn gets demoted I can bring
up the rules again I'm still learning
like the the demotions and promotions
I've not had their special hands called
an empress in the palace I think I had
the Empress actually Palace I haven't
had yet let's put the bishop let's face
a night here first
[Music]
yeah two queens would just overpower me
so what does stock this have oh how's a
queen okay well I'm gonna be worse but
I'll have two minor pieces for the Queen
I could place a bishop maybe on eight
shades actually everything's defended my
Knights defend each other and each night
defends a bishop and I'm attacking the
Queen my bishop in the corner please
don't see it yeah the way to get to
Queens is to have it's like some
promotion okay it's not the end of the
world
I mean I'm worse here but I'm gonna try
and hold my own now it does take work
for white to crack this position
and also timewise timelines I think I'll
be in relatively good shape let's play
plateless it's hard to generate threats
but I guess the strategy is just to be
patient I should probably take I'll play
95 kind of a nice outpost square it's
actually a very hard structure for for
white to crack
my light squares are arguably weak but
there's not really much I can do to
exploit them a my night actually my
night controls lots of he light squares
actually both nights okay
ya know like in a longer game it would
be very hard to play this fair win and
what would be the one trying to grind
down but for now life is good
a flag flag is pretty much inevitable I
should have a match against the other
Eric some day I played him over the
board okay
exchange of emotes I won I won on time
that was nice I mean yeah just tough
when yes when you can't convert the
material advantage not a great hand I'm
just gonna be aggressive with betting
it's probably not a great decision but
I'm just curious what my opponent will
do
ooh one's calling doesn't call my bluff
this is that's probably one of the worst
hands
I'm gonna check as well if I got a queen
I'm gonna shove okay I got a pawn gets
promoted to a rook I'll check the pot is
almost 5000 chips this is yeah this is
one versus one and we have multiple
rounds of like betting and placement
okay so we'll see see what's going on
here
I'm no employee a solid setup as I'm
scared like because he called he
probably has good cards one in the world
am i watching you're watching choker
combination of chess and poker so we got
through the betting phase this is a
placement favs pawns can be placed
second through fourth ranked pieces just
on the first two rings light will move
first
ooh symmetrical hmm I think the bishop
bishop is typically happy on c2 it
complements the pawn chain as d3 d4 or
f5 they're all anchor points and maybe
the knight can also come into play like
9 f1 could actually be a quite useful
square eventually coming to g3 and f5 ok
have to be careful about the bishop it's
a problem the dark squares are a weak
it's a little bit unsettling using my
night to control some dark squares ooh
this could be very unpleasant especially
if lack has a queen I guess we'll find
out
okay what okay
oh no oh that's a ruck Oh beautiful okay
so I couldn't ooh
actually this is interesting that's a
rook promise blocks threatening Bishop
f2 I can't really throw in the check
III might actually be reasonable bishop
g6 also playable I think I'll play III
because I saw Bishop f2 and I'm
threatening Bishop efore and the rook is
just tied down to the bishop
yeah castling is possible but now Bishop
f4 now I should be winning material but
if I win the exchange it'll be equal
material napkins asking an interesting
strategy question should you always put
the most valuable most powerful pieces
last I think so I think it makes the
most sense because you don't want to
reveal and you don't want to admit your
strongest pieces because they can
generate the most initiative once you
know kind of the overall placement of
your opponent ESA's but there might be
some maybe some reason to do so not
entirely sure okay let's
ooh wait a minute this is a free rook
but I can take with either thing
let's take with bishop
and now the bishop is hanging on III ya
sockless should have moved somewhere
else art Vega art Vega 1983 thanks for
the raid appreciate that
that's a new name is that a chest
streamer or poker streamer or art
streamer before the stream started I was
looking for the choker category on
Twitch but there's no such category so
maybe someday once this game becomes
more popular oh it is at rest streamer
okay I'll have to to give a follow and a
shout-out yeah after this after the
stream I'll take a look thanks again
okay let's do this yeah this is a big
pot opponents gonna lose most of the
chips
wait till I type it in wrong oh I typed
in Vegas oops let me try let me try that
one more time
they're just typing reflexes there we go
[Music]
okay I won the pot another [ __ ] I think
no matter what I'm just going on right
now and the pain and maybe I'll go
all-in before only after the first two
cards Oh opponents resigned yeah I think
these these stats need to be improved
but okay that was uh that was certainly
a an interesting experience streaming
just a new game where I do have the
chess background but there is still
strategy to figure out I know there are
there are some improvements on the
technical side some of the game's not
not competing but yeah feel free to give
feedback in the chat I know there is
there's probably going to be a lot more
updates to this app and there will be I
think more content
I know Nakamura has been streaming this
some bits there's some stuff on YouTube
people can search for but and I might
even put this whole stream on YouTube
I'll see I might cut it up we'll see
people watching in the future on YouTube
let me know what you think in the
comments